The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So yeah, but
today, what we're going to do
is talk about evolution.
And in particular,
we're going to complete
our discussion of
evolution in the presence
of clonal interference when
multiple mutant lineages are
competing in the
population a the same time.
And then, we'll move
on to try to think
about evolution on these
so-called rugged fitness
landscapes.
So such ruggedness
occurs when there
are interactions between the
mutations within the organism.
So a so-called
epistatic interactions
can, perhaps, constrain
the path of evolution.
So we'll complete our discussion
of Roy Kashoney's paper
on the equivalence
principle and the presence
of clonal interference.
Then we'll say something about
how clonal interference slows
down the rate of evolution.
It slows down the rate at which
the population can increase
in fitness because
of this competition
between different
beneficial lineages.
And then, we'll
discuss this paper
by Daniel Weinreich,
which I think,
for many of us, had a
real important effect
in just terms of getting
us to think about evolution
in a different way.
Any questions before?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Question
about the exam.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
In case you've
tried to forget, we
have an exam again next week.
So research and
education indicates that
the more exams, the better.
So if that makes you feel any
better in terms of process,
then use that.
So next Thursday, 7 o'clock, we
will announce the room later.
Did you have a
question about that?
AUDIENCE: Is it everything
from the start or [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so it will be
weighted towards the material
that we did not test
through exam one.
But you can expect to
get two plus or minus
1 questions on material
that was covered
in the first part of the class.
OK.
Any other questions?
All right, so coming
back to this discussion
of the equivalence principle.
So the last figure of the
paper-- it's a figure of four--
illustrated some alternative
underlying distribution.
So what we wanted to
know is-- all right,
so they're going to be
some beneficial mutations
that these E.coli can get
in this new environment.
And they're going to distributed
according to some probability
distribution.
So what we, in
principle, want to know
is this distribution of effects
of beneficial mutations.
So the probability of
distribution, P beneficial,
is a function of s.
And what was, kind of, the
scale of beneficial mutations
that they observe in the paper.
All right, how much
better do the populations
get after these few
100 generations?
Hm?
AUDIENCE: 1%.
PROFESSOR: All right, so
[? order of ?] percent.
A few percent, right?
Precisely.
And indeed, they had
three different models
for some of the
underlying distributions
and how they might behave.
So they had the exponential
uniform and the [INAUDIBLE]
kind of delta function.
And in all these
cases, are those
the only three possible
underlying distributions?
Those are just, kind of,
typical distributions.
What you want, in this case,
is you want these three degree
distributions to, somehow,
be qualitatively different
so you can drive home
the point that you
can, in principle, describe
the results of their evolution
experiment via wildly different
underlying distributions.
OK.
Now in all these cases,
you have to specify
the mutation rate, as well as
the mean selection coefficient.
All right, so the mean
of this distribution.
OK, now the question is, can
we get any intuitive insight
into why there were the patterns
that they observe in terms
of the mutation rate
that they had to assume
and the mean
selection coefficient.
There were some region of
parameter space for those two
distributions, for each of those
distributions, that were, kind
of, consistent with their data.
So in particular, there
was a mutation rate-- mu--
for the exponential
distribution,
a mutation rate for the
uniform, and a mutation rate
for the delta function.
And also, there was
a mean s associated
with the exponential,
mean s for the uniform
and, again, a mean
s for the delta.
AUDIENCE: Were they trying to
minimize the parameter numbers?
PROFESSOR: Right.
OK, so in this case, they
wanted to compare these three
distributions.
Each of them were specified
by two parameters.
You could come up with other
underlying distributions that
might, for example,
have a larger
number that might be specified
by a larger number parameters.
But then, it's harder to
compare the quality of the fit
and so forth.
So they chose these
three distributions
just because this
is, somehow, the rate
that these new mutations will
appear in the population.
And then, this tells us
something about how good
those mutations are.
Right.
Now some of you have the
paper in front of you.
And that's OK.
But based on our understanding
of how the clonal interference,
kind of, manifests itself
in terms of leading,
eventually, they have
the log of the fraction.
So the fraction
starts out 50-50.
Log F1 over F2.
So like, cyan and yellow, say?
All right.
So this thing starts out here.
And then, one side gets
beneficial mutation.
So it, kind of, comes up.
So they measure the
slope, for example,
of the lineage that is
taking over the population.
So they want to know, well,
which of these distributions
and associated
parameters will be
able to explain the range
of different trajectories
that they saw?
So the question is, can
we order these things?
And why?
All right, which
one of these should
be the largest, second largest,
third largest, and so forth?
OK.
Now it's OK if you
just-- well, if you
had the paper in front of you,
you could just read it off.
But ultimately,
you're going to have
to be able to explain
why it is that one
is larger than the other.
OK?
So what I want to know is, for
example, at what order should
these things come in?
All right.
So what I want to do is let you
think about it for a minute.
And then, we're going
to vote by putting
our cards from
high mutation rate
to low mutation rate
among a, b, and c.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So the means are
constrained to be the same?
PROFESSOR: So it's really going
to be some range of parameters
on each of these.
So the question is, why is it
that in the range of parameters
that are consistent with what
they observe experimentally,
that these things
have some order?
Are there any other
questions about the question?
I'll give you 30
seconds to think
about what the
mutation rate should,
kind of, be in this situation.
AUDIENCE: The answer is highest
to lowest mutation rate.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So you're going to put the
highest mutation rate up high,
the lowest mutation
rate down there,
and the middle one in between.
Yeah.
All right.
Do you need more time?
All right, let's
see where we are.
And it's OK if you're
confused or don't
know what I'm trying to ask.
But let me see
where the group is.
Ready?
Three, two, one.
All right.
So I would say it's, pretty
much, all over the place,
whether people are voting
something in reality or not.
OK, right.
So the situation is that
we have the data, which
is shown in figure 3A, which is
a bunch of these things that,
kind of, look like this.
All right.
So we have some times.
We have some slopes.
We want to know how can
we understand that data
that we get out.
So what we're going
to do is we're
going to take a model
in which we say,
all right, we're going to start
with this population that's
all identical.
And then, we're going to allow
some mutations to accumulate.
And we're going to let them
compete against each other.
And then, see what
happens to the other.
So there's going to be some,
again, distribution of slopes
and so forth.
All right.
To what degree does
this sort of data
constrain that
underlying distribution?
Between something that
looks like an exponential,
something that has a
uniform distribution,
and something that
is a delta function.
So that's the exponential.
This is the delta.
And this is the uniform.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So we measure the
slope at what time [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, it could.
That's right.
So this thing could turn
around at various times.
So I think that there are
a number of different ways
that you could argue about
the right way to do this.
In practice, I
think it's not going
to be very sensitive because
there's a minority of them that
will actually be turning
around, for example.
So you could, for
example, just say
all of the trajectories
that cross some point,
I mean, measure the slope.
And I think that
would be sufficient.
AUDIENCE: But if you don't
see this fraction turn over,
you could still have
clonal interference?
PROFESSOR: If you
don't see the fraction.
AUDIENCE: Like, in the sense--
PROFESSOR: That's right.
So even if you don't see these
things like, the flatten out,
for example, then you could
still have clonal interference
because the slope
might still be steeper
than it would be in the
absence of clonal interference.
All right, what
I'm going to do is
I'm going to let you discuss
with a neighbor for one minute.
And then, we'll, maybe,
discuss as a group
just because I want to make sure
that everybody gets a chance
to try and verbalize
their thought process.
And if we discuss in a group,
then only a few of us get to.
All right, so one minute.
Try to discuss it
with your neighbor.
And then we'll reconvene.
[SIDE CONVERSATIONS]
Yeah, and we're going to
discuss the means in a moment.
So indeed, these
distributions will not
end up having the same mean s.
AUDIENCE: What are
you controlling?
PROFESSOR: What
we're controlling
is that we're asking
about what range
of parameters for
each distribution
will adequately fit the data.
AUDIENCE: I know [INAUDIBLE].
Does it depend on what you get?
PROFESSOR: The data
will be, basically,
the initial slopes
here and when they
deviated from a 50-50 mixture.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: All right, so
that's what [INAUDIBLE]
is those histograms.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
OK.
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: All right, so it
seems like we've quieted down,
which means that we all
agree on the answer.
Is that-- no?
OK, well I think that this
is, actually, pretty tricky.
So that's fine.
I just want to see
where we are, though.
All right.
Reconfigure your cards.
Your best guess for the
orders of the mutation rates
between exponential
uniform and delta.
All right, ready?
Three, two, one.
OK, so we're migrating
towards some things.
OK, great.
And can somebody verbalize the
answer that their group got?
AUDIENCE: So our
answer is A, B, and C.
PROFESSOR: OK.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
exponential [INAUDIBLE].
We can not see most
of the [INAUDIBLE]
lower selection
coefficient mutations.
PROFESSOR: OK.
AUDIENCE: So we're actually
underestimating the mutation
rate from the data.
PROFESSOR: Underestimate.
OK, no, I can see
what you're saying.
OK, yeah, so the
idea is that you're
saying that we don't see an
awful lot of the mutations
here, which means
that the true mutation
rate, the underlying
mutation rate
is, somehow, much larger than
you would have thought based
on the mutations that you
actually see here or something.
And there's maybe another.
OK, so they're different.
All right.
OK, it's certainly along--
yeah, sometimes it's true.
And then, of course, there are
different ways of saying this.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, same answer
but a slightly different way
of thinking about it.
If you're just randomly sampling
any of these distributions,
then your sample drawn from
the exponential distribution.
It's going to be low
selection [INAUDIBLE]
more often than it's going
to be for the other ones.
Like the delta is [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: That's right.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
every time the uniform.
It's going to be equally
likely to be a high selection
coefficient as opposed to a
low selection coefficient.
But with the exponential
distributions,
your most likely to be a
low selection coefficient.
So you want more mutations.
PROFESSOR: That's right.
You, somehow, need more
mutations of that exponential
in order to sample out there.
Right?
So which one is going to have
a more clonal interference?
Which of these
distributions will end up
having the most clonal
interference after you
fit the data?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: The one with
the highest mutation.
PROFESSOR: The one with the
highest mutation, right?
Kind of has to.
Of course, and even though
some of those mutations
are going to be loss,
still it's going
to have the most colonel
interference there.
And indeed, if the
underlying distribution
were modeling as
a delta function
and, in their
[? fit ?], what they got
was that this might be
around 5 and 1/2%, I think.
Yeah, so [? 5 to 5 and 1/2 ?].
OK.
So here, this guy
was around 0.055.
Between 5 and 5 and 1/2%.
So what they're saying
is, all right, well you
could explain all
of our data just
by assuming that there's
some mutation rate where,
periodically, some individual
gets a beneficial mutation that
is a 5, 5 and 1/2%.
And that could, in
principle, be used
to explain the base
features here, how long have
to wait before anything happens,
and the slope when something
starts happening.
So the histogram that they
plot is actually, somehow,
this initial this initial
slope once you start
seeing it deviate from 50/50.
OK?
All right.
But their point is
it that that does not
prove that the underlying
distribution is
a delta function
with some mutation.
And indeed, to explain the
data with a delta function,
you don't actually don't
need any clonal interference.
Right?
You just say, OK, well
somebody gets a mutation.
It's 5%.
And eventually, it's
going to spread.
And that's what we see.
If you want to explain the
later dynamics of flattening
out and so forth, then you
have to allow the other lineage
to get a mutations, as
well to cause a flattening.
But as far as the
base dynamics of when
you leave the 50-50
in the initial slope,
you don't even really need to
have any clonal interference
to explain their data with
a delta function underlined.
And that's why you also can
get by with a very low mutation
rate because you
don't really need much
in the way of
competing lineages.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: But what if the
slopes are [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, yeah.
No, right.
So you're not actually going
to get the true distribution
of slopes.
But their argument
is that a lot of that
could just be noise and
measuring the slopes
and so forth because, if
everything is a delta function,
then you would start out
by just getting one slope,
unless you offer multiple
mutations on a lineage.
And then, things could
get more complicated.
But yeah.
In this case, all of these
guys would have the same slope.
But that's, at least, a
reasonable first order
approximation to the data.
However, as you move to these
distributions in uniform
and exponential, you're going
to need more and more clonal
interference to, kind
of, explain the data.
So you'll need higher
and higher mutation rate.
What's interesting
is that you also
have a lower and lower mean s.
OK?
AUDIENCE: Can you
just explain why
you need to explain the data?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, sure.
And I think that drawing
these underlying distributions
is really helpful.
So first, we're going to
draw the delta function.
That, kind of,
makes sense that you
can fit everything just by
assuming 5, 5 and 1/2%, right.
So what we're going to
do is draw the various P.
So I drew those distributions.
But they weren't
necessarily to scale.
i.e, they didn't necessarily
have the proper mean selection
coefficient.
What we can do
here is we can draw
this is the mean s of
the delta function, which
was 5, 5 and 1/2%.
All right, we got this guy here.
Now the question
is can we describe
the data using a
uniform distribution
with the same mean
selection coefficient?
All right, so we're going
to have you vote yes and no.
And if you say no,
then you have to say
what's going to go wrong.
All right?
The question is can we just
use the same mean selection
coefficient for our
uniform distribution.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right.
So what we're going
to do is we're
going to measure the
experiment where we would have,
say, 96 different evolutionary
trajectories where we measure
the time that it takes for
something to happen and then
the initial slope.
And we're going to take a
histogram of those things,
and compare it
between what we would
get in the model with what
we got experimentally.
All right, the
question is can we
use the same mean
s for a uniform
as we did for the
delta function.
And if you say no, you
have to say why not.
A is yes.
B is no.
Ready?
Three, two, one.
All right, so we
have a bunch of no's.
Maybe a few yes's.
All right but then
some of the no's,
it's incumbent on
you [INAUDIBLE].
So I don't know.
So yes, so one of
the no's, why not?
AUDIENCE: So if we
have [INAUDIBLE]
if it has the same
average, then there
are going to be
outliers that are more
better for the [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: That's right.
So the problem here is that, if
we use the same mean selection
coefficient pretty
for the uniform,
then what we're
going to end up with
is something that
comes out twice as far.
AUDIENCE: Wait.
But the delta function is just
a uniform distribution with 0.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So you could always
just fit it with [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
we're assuming it's
a uniform distribution
that starts at 0
and then goes out to
some [? amount ?].
Yeah.
So the idea is that--
I mean, whatever.
That's the model.
And I think it's
a reasonable model
because we know that there
are a lot of mutations
that have little effect.
So it makes sense for a
distribution to start at 0,
if you're going to have
something like a uniform.
Right?
And the problem with such
a uniform distribution
is that because there's going
to be some clonal interference,
what that means is that
you're going to be, kind of,
weighted out here.
And that means that
you'll, kind of,
see mutations that are
out here around 10%,
instead of around 5%.
So what you actually
want, then, is
something where
the mean selection
coefficient is
around half of what
you had as the delta function.
So you want something that
really looks more like this.
And that's actually why,
if you look at the data
or if you look at this
figure, then the area that
works for the
uniform distribution
has a mean/coefficient of 3%.
So this thing comes
out to around 6% here.
So just beyond the s correspond
to the delta function.
So this is the delta.
And this is the uniform.
So here is around 6%.
And the mean of this is
[? at half ?] of that.
Right?
What's happening is that there's
some clonal interference.
And you only need a modest
amount of clonal interference
because if you sample from a
uniform distribution just a few
then, the most fir one
will be around here.
And it'll already be
relatively peaked.
And of course, there's
also this issue
that you have to survive
stochastic extinction.
So that amplifies
the effect further.
So really, if you just have,
say, two mutations sampled
from the uniform that survives
stochastic extinction,
you're already going
to get something
that's peaked around there.
Does that make sense?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: But what
if we [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: So then, the
question is what exact mutation
rate do you need.
And basically, you need a
high enough mutation rate
that you get some
mutations and that you can
have some clonal interference.
And the question is,
what prevents you
from having a mutation rate
that's too high, maybe?
AUDIENCE: My question was why
do you need clonal interference
to explain the data.
PROFESSOR: Ah, right.
AUDIENCE: I mean, of course, you
have these [INAUDIBLE] focused
on what happened early on.
PROFESSOR: That's right.
Yeah.
Right, OK.
So in there it comes
down to how peaked
this distribution of
slopes is because there
are very few shallow slopes.
And of course, then, it gets
into questions about quality
of data and so forth.
And that's more subtle.
But certainly in
principal, in the absence
of clonal interference, you
would have some fair number
of shallow slopes.
It would be under
represented just
because of the stochastic
extinction business.
But still, you need some
to explain the, sort of,
peakiness of that distribution
of the slope distribution.
Now the exponential
is interesting
because it's in a very,
very different regime.
So I just want to show this
is mean s for the uniform.
And actually, if you
look at the figure
of the mean s for
the exponential,
it's down there around
1%, which is a little bit
surprising because
what this is saying
is that, if you look
at this distribution,
this initial slope, kind
of, extends down here.
And you have something
that falls off,
dramatically, though, right.
OK.
So how is it possible
that you could
use such a distribution
that's peaked over here
that's so far over on the
left and still explain
the same data?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: That's right.
So it's true that I've drawn
this, kind of, around 0.
But the exponential
and principle
goes to [? infinity ?].
It's just that it falls
off exponentially.
But what this means is that
you're sampling pretty far
out on the exponential in order
to get the same mean effect.
So you're actually going
out to five or six times
this characteristic s.
So you're talking
e to the minus 5.
Right?
That means there's a lot
of clonal interference
that has to be happening in
order to explain this, right?
But why is it that
it's way over here?
I mean, why not just use an
exponential with an s that's
more like 3, 4, 5, 6%?
What's that?
Well OK.
But, you know, I mean,
this is just a model.
I can do whatever I want
because, actually, they fit
their data with these models.
So realistic just means
that it explains their data.
So there's nothing a priori
wrong with saying, oh,
here's an exponential with a
characteristic fall off of 5%.
That's, in principle, fine.
I mean, it doesn't
work, for some reason,
but we have to figure out why.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK, right.
So you're likely going to get a
low selection coefficient, OK.
Is that the problem?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK, that's true.
But I guess the question
is why can't we use?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Two mutations?
Two clusters?
What do you mean?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK, the
time between two.
OK, that's an
interesting statement.
Although, the region or
parameter space that they claim
works is actually a region where
we have a really high mutation
rate.
Orders of magnitude higher than
the other two distributions.
So in that sense, the
time between mutations
being established
is really small
because they're saying
that, oh, if you
want to fit the
[INAUDIBLE] exponential,
then you have to assume
lots of clonal interference.
So that means the time between
successive establishments
or mutations is really,
actually, very short.
So that's actually the regime
where they claim works.
So the question is
why is it that we
can't go to this other regime?
In this figure
that they make, why
is it that the allowed mean
coefficient doesn't extend out
to over there?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right.
AUDIENCE: Because
the exponential is
[INAUDIBLE] that [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: That's right.
Yeah, that's right.
The point is that, to
explain their data,
you need something to
cause this distribution
to get more peaked
over here, which
means you need to have a fair
amount of clonal interference.
But that means you need to
have a high mutation rate.
But once you have that
high mutation rate,
if you have an exponential
that comes out here,
then you would actually
sample way out here, as well.
So the only way to get a
peaks distribution around here
is to have it so that
the exponential is really
suppressing those
really good mutations.
But you have a lot of
clonal interference
that, kind of, pulls things out.
Now there still is a fair range
of parameters that work here.
You know, it goes from,
say, half a percent up
to, maybe, 1 and 1/2% in
terms of this mean selection
coefficient.
And the mutation rate
that works then changes.
So as you got a larger
mean selection coefficient,
the mutation rate
that is compatible
goes down because you need
less clonal interference.
So that's why, if you look at
this figure for the region that
works in terms of
the mutation rate
for the beneficial
mutation and the mean s,
there's some region that
looks, kind of, like this
that works for the exponential.
And this is,
actually, a big range.
So this is, actually, a
factor of 100 in mutation rate
that would be compatible.
And then, a factor of, maybe,
three in mean selection
coefficient.
So there's some range
of parameters that work.
And you can understand why
it is that this thing has
to be shaped the way it is.
Does that make sense?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right because
the uniform is out here.
And then, the delta
function is here.
So this is delta,
uniform, and exponential.
And you're just saying that it
all, [? kind of ?], following.
Is that-- yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, well maybe
some power law fall off
would do that.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: There's nothing
there's nothing magic
about these three regions.
And it's not that we're
claiming that the mean selection
coefficient cannot be in here.
It's just that, if you
pick these three underlined
distributions, you get this
range of different values
that would work.
So if you chose other
underlying distributions,
you could get other blogs.
But it's true that
there is a general trend
that, the higher the mean
selection coefficient,
the less clonal
interference you need
or want to explain the data.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right.
Why can't it go higher or lower?
Yeah.
I don't know.
A factor of 100
isn't enough for you?
Yeah, it's a good question.
I'd have to think about
it to figure out which--
because there's going to be a
different effect on each side,
presumably.
Yeah, and all of
these distributions,
there's some floor
just because we
know that you have to get
these beneficial mutations
within the first few
tens of generations.
Otherwise, the mutation
wouldn't have gotten a chance
to spread when it did.
So that means we
know that there's
going to be a lower
bound on the mutation
always because, if
it's too low, then we
wouldn't have gotten
the mutations in time.
And now, in terms of why
it can't be higher, yeah,
I'd have to think about it.
Are there any other
questions about this paper?
I think it's a challenging
paper, kind of,
conceptually/mathematically.
But I think it's
interesting because it
does get you to think about this
process of clonal interference
in new ways.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So is that enough?
Like, is this condition
rate known [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Oh, I see.
Oh, that's a good question.
Yeah.
Yeah, so I think
that the mutation
rates that-- first of all, this
is not a per base pair mutation
rate.
This is the rate that you
get beneficial mutations.
So I'd say, the numbers
are not ridiculous.
But it's not that
you can just take
the known per base [? pair of ?]
mutation rate and say, oh, well
it has to be here because
an awful lot of them
are deleterious.
And it's very sensitive
because the mutations that
are occurring around
here don't really
matter for evolution because
they tend not to survive
stochastic extinction.
They're not going to
survive clonal interference.
Yet, it could be a big
part of the distribution.
Right?
It could be that the majority
of the mutations-- for example,
in the exponential-- is there.
So you can actually have
very different distributions
that don't really change
the evolutionary process
but would change the rate
of beneficial mutations.
So I think the numbers
are not ridiculous.
But it's hard to
constrain, actually.
What I want to do
is, before talking
about these rugged
fitness landscapes
and the Weinreich paper,
let's just say something
about the rate of evolution.
And when we say
rate, we're referring
to the change and the mean
fitness of the population
with respect to time.
All right, so this is
the rate of evolution.
So this is the change
in the mean fitness.
Delta.
Delta mean fitness
divided by delta time.
So what we want to
do is just start
by thinking about
a situation where
we assume that we're not all
running out of new mutations
that are good for us.
All right, so what we can do is
just assume that, at some rate,
mu-- so there's at rate
mu beneficial, we'll say.
We sample from some
probabilities distribution
of beneficial mutations.
And then, something happens
to cast an extinction.
Maybe clonal
interference and whatnot.
But someone of them will fix.
And then, that
increases the fitness.
And then, for now, we'll just
assume that the fitness is add.
But for small S's,
it doesn't matter
whether we're thinking
about [? fitness as ?]
adding or multiplying.
You guys understand
what I just said there?
So if you get a mutation
that has affect S1 and maybe
the right way to think
about this is that,
if you get a mutation s2, then
the [? fitnesses ?] perhaps ,
should multiply as
the [? mu ?] model.
But this is, of course,
for a small s1 and s2,
this is around 1 plus s2.
So for small S's for
short times, maybe
we don't need to worry about
this because this is, for s1
and s2, much less than 1.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: My intuition would
be that, if you already
had a 5% increase
i [? fitness ?],
it would be harder
to get [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: That's right.
So eventually, that
certainly is going
to be the case that
we're going to run out
of these beneficial mutations.
But for the first few
thousand generations,
it's roughly linear.
So eventually, it does
start curving over.
But maybe not as fast as
you would have thought.
And at the very least, this
is a good [? no ?] model.
And then, we can, of course,
complicate things later.
But for now, we'll just
assume that you always
sample from the same
probability distribution
of beneficial mutations,
just for simplicity.
The question is, how fast will
the fitness of the population
increase with time?
OK?
Do you guys understand
the question?
All right, let's start by
thinking about the regime where
mu b N is much less than 1.
So very low rates of mutation
relative to the population
size.
Now you might recall--
for clonal interference.
So clonal interference
not relevant.
What we found last
time was it required
that the time that it
took for mutation to fix
had to be much
less than the time
between successive
establishments
of these beneficial mutations.
And this was 1 over s log N's.
You should be able to
[? derive ?] both of these.
This and that and this,
and the next step, as well.
All right, so you can
ignore clonal interference
if this is true.
So let's say that we can
ignore clonal interference.
So for small population
sizes or in the limit
of low mutation rates.
What we want to know is
the rate of evolution.
How will it scale
with various things?
I'll go ahead and
have us vote for-- OK.
How does it scale with,
[? particular ?], both,
the mutation rate and
the population size?
It's proportional to what?
Holding another
thing is constant.
Holding, for example, the
distribution and n constant.
OK?
Do you understand the question?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK.
So this is just the rate
of beneficial mutations.
And this is just
to the 0th power.
i.e, it doesn't defend.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
PROFESSOR: Linearly,
it's squared.
All right, ready?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, assuming that
clonal interference is not
relevant.
So assuming, for a
small mutation rate,
how does it scale
in mutation rate?
OK, ready.
Three, two, one.
All right, so we got a
lot of B's, which is nice.
So this is saying that, indeed,
if mutation rate is small,
then there's going to be
some rate that mutations
enter into the population.
They may or may not survive
stochastic extinction.
But if they do, and that
doesn't depend on mutation rate,
then they can fix.
And in this low
mutation rate regime,
they don't compete
with each other.
In which case, if you double
the rate of these things entered
into the population,
you'll double the rate
that they get established.
And you'll double the rate that
these beneficial mutations will
fix in the population
So you double the rate.
OK?
All right, now as
a function of n.
Does it go as N
to the 0 or other?
We got A, B, C, D. All right,
I'll give you 15 seconds
to think about it.
Ready?
Three, two, one.
OK, so now we're getting
more disagreement.
All right.
And I'd say,
largely, A's and B's.
All right, there's
enough disagreement.
Let's go ahead and
spend just 30 seconds.
Turn to your neighbor.
[SIDE CONVERSATIONS]
Per individual, yeah.
All right, let's go
ahead and re-vote
just so I can see where we are.
How is it that the
rate of evolution
in this regime, no
clonal interference,
how is this going to
scale the population size?
Ready?
Three, two, one.
OK
So, I'd say that we have
not really convinced
each other of anything.
All right, so A's B's?
Somebody explain the reasoning.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
mutation rate [INAUDIBLE]
larger the population,
the larger we're
going to get
[INAUDIBLE] population.
PROFESSOR: OK.
All right, so if you double
the size of the population,
you'll double the rate
the new mutations enter
into the population.
AUDIENCE: And the
other important thing
is that the fixation time
just goes, like, [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK, right.
So then there's the
fixation time business.
So how is that relevant?
Yeah, somebody that said A, what
was your partners reasoning?
Or where you convinced
by this argument?
Or confused.
AUDIENCE: Well if it's
[INAUDIBLE], then the
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Ah.
Right, so if it's a nearly
new [INAUDIBLE] mutation,
then it's true that the
[INAUDIBLE] would be 1/N but--
AUDIENCE: But if N is very
large then, sometimes,
s will not [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK, right.
But now you're
invoking N being large,
which I don't think we
necessarily want to do.
I mean, I guess there are a
couple things to say there.
One is that the mutations
that are really nearly neutral
will not have a very significant
effect on the fitness.
And within that
regime, I think, yeah,
you'd have to check what
happens there, right?
But I think that, in most of
these cases, small population,
we're often saying population
[? must be ?] 10 to the 4
or so.
In which case, the
nearly neutral mutations
are not very relevant.
Right?
So indeed, over a broad range of
conditions, in this situation,
it's going to scale as
N. So the rate, so far,
it's going to equal to
there's a mu b times an N.
And that's basically because
the rate the new mutations enter
into the populations is mu
N. And the rate that they get
established is just mu N's.
This is, indeed, what this
calculation is telling us.
Now the question is, how much
of a fitness gain will we get?
How is it going to scale with
this probability distribution.
So this probability
distribution will give us
some function of s.
So this distribution
has to be relevant.
Do we agree?
So we want to know in
what way is it relevant.
Is it relevant via the
mean, via the mean squared,
the mean cubed-- I don't know--
the mean squared, or other?
This one is harder.
So it's worth spending,
I'll give you,
a full 30 seconds
to think about it.
So the question is, how
is it that the probability
distribution will enter
into the rate of evolution
in this situation?
OK?
Question.
No?
AUDIENCE: Can [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: I'm
sorry, multiple what?
AUDIENCE: Is it
possible that it's
entered in multiple situation?
PROFESSOR: Oh, yeah.
You know, this is why
I gave you flashcards.
You can put up any
combination you want.
Another 15 seconds.
This one is trickier.
Let's go ahead and vote.
Ready?
Three, two, one.
All right, so we got
a lot of A's and B's.
Some, maybe, C's and D's.
All right, so yeah.
We're pretty far.
OK, we're all over the place.
All right, so there's going
to be some distribution.
There might be, for example,
probability distribution
function of s, function of s.
We want to know it's
going to something that's
going to fall off in some way.
Maybe exponential.
Maybe something else.
Now to keep track of
this, what we need to do
is remember that the probability
of establishment goes as s.
The probability
of establishment.
And the [INAUDIBLE]
model is equal to s.
In other models, it might be 2s.
But it's around s.
And then, the question
is, how much of a benefit
will you get if
you do establish?
All right.
And that is, again,
going to go as--
and whatever the delta fitness
is actually, again, equal
to whatever acid is
that you sampled.
And the given mutation that
appeared, you sample somewhere.
It has to, both, survive and
well- if it survives, then
it gives you an s.
So what that means is
that, actually, you
end up averaging s squared
of the distribution
to determine the
rate of evolution.
If it was just a
delta function at s,
then it's just an s squared.
So then you think, oh, it's
going to be mean of x squared.
Right?
But if it's a delta
function, then the mean
of s squared and the mean s
squared are the same thing.
But in this situation,
it's just useful to play
with some different
distributions
and see how it plays out.
But in this case, it is,
indeed, mean s squared.
So the rate of evolution in the
limit of no clonal interference
is, actually, rather simple.
It just goes as mu
N. But then, you
have to take the
expectation of s
squared of whatever
this distribution is
of underlying mutations.
OK?
But of course, this
is going to break down
at some point, as
everything does.
And can somebody
remind us why it is
that it's going to break down?
Clonal interference.
Perfect.
And we know exactly where
clonal interference is going
to start being relevant here.
In particular,
what we can imagine
drawing is something
that's [INAUDIBLE]
the rate of evolution
as a function of N.
So rate is a function
of N. And we might even
want to plot in
a log, log scale.
So we'll say the
log of the rate.
The log of N.
And at the beginning, what
do I draw here for small n?
A line with slope 1.
OK.
If i had depended
on n squared, then
what would I be drawing here?
A line with slope 2.
Yep.
Don't mess that up because
it's really easy to.
OK, so it's a line with slope 1.
Right?
So at the beginning, for
small population size,
if you double the
population size,
you should double the
rate of evolution.
But this can't go on
forever, and it won't.
So it's going to
curve over somewhere.
all right.
AUDIENCE: How can the
rate go down [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: the rate goes down
relative to what it would have
if it had continued.
And that's because
you're wasting
some beneficial mutations.
With clonal interference,
what's happening
is that you have a
great mutation over here
but also a great
mutation over here.
And only one of those
great mutations can win.
So with clonal
interference, you're,
somehow, wasting some of
the beneficial mutations
that you acquired.
AUDIENCE: Even
though you're always
taking the maximum
because what you're doing
is you're [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right
because the alternative
would have been to take
the sum of them, which
is what happens over here.
If they're not competing,
then you got one.
And you get the other.
And you just get
higher and higher.
With clonal interference,
you indeed take the maximum.
But that's lower than sum.
And that affect just
gets worse and worse
as you get to larger
population sizes.
So although it's
relatively simple
to calculate the
rate of evolution
in the limit of
small populations,
the rate of evolution in the
case of clonal interference
is, actually, a
very hard problem.
Hard, well, experimentally,
theoretically, and in all ways.
I just want to say a few things.
There have been some really,
I think, interesting studies
occurring over the last 10 years
trying to get at this regime.
So the question is
how should it behave.
And there's a paper by
Desai, Fisher, and Murray
when they were all at Harvard.
Since then, Daniel
Fisher, the [INAUDIBLE],
has moved to Stanford.
Desai went to Princeton but
then came back to Harvard.
So he's now Harvard faculty.
So this is current
biology in 2006, '07, '08.
It's 2007.
So they have, kind of,
a simplification of this
where they asked
let's just assume
that we don't have a
probability distribution
of beneficial mutations.
Instead, let's just assume
that there's some mutation rate
to acquire beneficial
mutation that's exactly s.
OK?
So you say, all right, well
that sounds super simple.
Of course, it's not true.
But even that problem is hard.
But what they can
do in this regime
is that then it's nice because
everything's, kind of, discrete
because then the
population is going
to described by a
series of-- so this
is abundance as a
function of the fitness.
So this is, maybe, the bulk
minus fitness relative 0.
Here, this is s, 2s, 3s, 4s, and
maybe there's a little bit here
at 5s.
OK?
So what happens is
that there's going
to be some equilibrium
distribution of this front
or the nose of the population.
And at some rate, these
guys get mutations
where some individual, kind of,
comes like this because it gets
a mutation that's beneficial.
But that doesn't actually
affect the dynamics
very much because all these
guys are growing exponentially.
What's really relevant
are when individuals that
have several or more of
these beneficial mutations
than the rest of the population,
when these guys get a mutation
that they can move forward.
And it's this dynamic
that is, kind of,
pulling the population here.
So you can actually do analytic
calculations on this model
that you would not be able to do
if you did a full distribution
of mutations here.
But it's actually still
complicated and hard.
And I do not claim to have gone
through the full derivation
because the full
thing is they get
that the velocity in this
model approximately equal to.
By then, it's an s squared.
All right, so you might sneer
at this model and say, oh, well,
you know, this is an
oversimplification,
blah, blah, blah.
But even this is hard.
And you get a
complicated expression.
And it's describing
something fundamental
that's happening in
these populations
with clonal interference.
The important thing is that
you can-- more or less,
this term is going to be the
dominant one in many cases,
especially because we're
interested in the large end
regime here.
So what you see is that,
for large N in this model
and they did experiments
in this paper that
are consistent
with it, they find
that the velocity-- the rate of
evolution-- this is the rate.
You see her the s squared term
that we already talked about.
Right?
And there's no
probability distribution,
so it's just an s squared.
But what you see is that it ends
up going as log N for large N.
So this is when there's a
lot of clonal interference.
So maybe this thing
goes as log N.
But I'd say, maybe, this is
not an open and shut case
because real populations are
more complicated than this
because it's not that every
mutation has magnitude s.
But I think it's a
reasonable first order model.
And I think this is a
nice set of calculations
to make sense of things.
Are there any questions
about that calculation
or why this thing
curves off [INAUDIBLE]?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Sure.
OK, so the question is why is
it that it's average s squared
instead of average s squared?
So what is it that's
useful to say?
I'm trying to think of a
nice probability distribution
where those things will
have very different--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: For a
delta distribution,
they're the same thing.
So if we wanted to do an
intuitive explanation, maybe,
[? probably ?]-- I'm
trying to think if we
had two delta distributions.
So the mean s would be here.
Yeah, OK.
So imagine that--
I know that this
is not a real beneficial
mutation so maybe but OK.
But it's something that's small.
You know, negligently small
here and magnitude s over here.
So the mean s is, indeed,
equal to this s 0 over 2.
Right?
Whereas, the mean of s squared
is, then, s squared 0 over 4.
Are we looking at
something different?
Oh, no.
OK, I think I'm going to have
to come up with a better example
to answer.
So maybe after class we
can come up with one.
I don't want to take
five minutes finding
a good explanation.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
so this is the rate
of evolution in the regime
of large population size.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: And I
don't know how small
you have to go before
[? funny ?] [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: That's only for
the [? large ?] [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yep.
Yeah, and, of course,
you could imagine
that taking various limits
is complicated here.
But the important
thing is that the rate
goes as log N for, in the
case, a clonal interference
because that's the key thing
to remember, besides the fact
that they actually had to
work to analyze this model.
OK, so what I want to do is,
in the last 10, 15 minutes,
to talk about this
[INAUDIBLE] paper
because I think it's pretty.
And I mean, it's
an elegant example
of how, if you look at a
problem in a different way,
then you can get, I think,
really interesting insights
using a minimal amount
of, like, measurements.
I mean, basically, how many
measurements are in this paper?
AUDIENCE: 32.
PROFESSOR: Basically, 32.
Right?
So what they are doing is
they're analyzing mutations
in the enzyme beta
lactamase or the gene
encoding beta lactamase,
which confers resistance
to beta lactam drugs like,
in this case, cefataxime
OK, so this guy gives
resistance to these beta lactam
drugs that are like
ampicillin or penicillin.
In this case, cefataxime.
but not all of the versions
of this gene or the enzyme,
actually, can break
down this new drug.
So all 32 versions of the
enzyme that they study
break down, for
example, ampicillin.
But they had widely varying
levels of resistance or ability
to break down this
drug, cefataxime.
So they wanted to try
to understand something
about what happens if you
start out with this base
version of the enzyme.
You know, if you
just look up what's
the sequence for beta lactamase.
What's going to be the sequence?
And that we're going to call
the minus, minus, minus, minus,
minus.
And we might,
reasonably, want to know
how does it get to the version
of the enzyme that has all five
of these [? point ?] mutations?
Does anybody remember what
those five mutations were?
Like, what kind of
mutations are they?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: They're all
[? point ?] mutations.
And are they all protein
coding mutations?
No.
So actually, this
one here is actually
a promoter mutation that
increases expression
by a factor of two or three.
Whereas, these things
here are indeed protein
coding and change
the amino acid.
Protein coding.
The amino acids in the end.
Well they each change one amino
acid in the resulting protein.
So what Weinreich
in this paper was
trying to understand is what
is the shape of these fitness
landscapes?
And what does that mean
about the course of evolution
or the repeatability or
predictability of evolution?
And I just want to stress
this is the Weinreich
2006 because this version
of the gene/enzyme
is, essentially, unable to
break down cefataxime at all.
So E-coli that has
this version of enzyme,
it's almost as if they don't
have any enzyme at all.
Whereas, this
version of the enzyme
is able to break down this drug,
cefataxime, at very high rates.
And indeed, the way
that these things
are quantified in this paper is
we have what's known as the MIC
or the Minimum
Inhibitory Concentration.
And basically, you
just ask-- oops,
inhibitory
concentration-- what's
the minimum amount
of the antibiotic
that you have to add
to prevent growth
of the bacterial population
after 20 hours starting
from some standard
cell density, OK?
So it's a very easy
experiment to do
because, 96 well [? plate ?],
you just have many wells.
And you just go down a
concentration, maybe,
by a factor of a
root 2 each time.
So then, you go across 12 or 24.
And you get over a broad range
of antibiotic concentrations.
And what you should see
is that this is, maybe,
dividing by route 2 each time.
So you get growth here.
You get growth here.
Growth here but then no
growth, no growth, no growth.
And the concentration and that
you added here is the MIC.
What you'll see
is that, depending
on the version of the enzyme
that the bacteria have,
the growth will occur up to
different concentrations.
AUDIENCE: Why would
you [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Why would you?
Why is that--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Oh, I'm
just telling you
what they actually did
experimentally in this paper.
You could do a factor of 2.
Or it's just a question how
fine of a resolution you want.
How to do root 2?
OK, so this is like a
mathematicians question,
all right because your
point is going to be that--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] route 2.
PROFESSOR: OK, so it's true.
Root 2, it's an
irrational number.
It's the first proof
in a analysis textbook.
It doesn't matter, OK?
Our error in pipe
heading is a percent,
which means that if you
do 1.41, that's fine.
Yes.
So don't be paralyzed
by petting a root 2.
OK?
AUDIENCE: Is it always very
sharp, this changing in growth?
PROFESSOR: You know,
biology and the word
always should never be
used in the same sentence.
I'd say that it's a
reasonable [? assay. ?]
It's, typically, sharp.
It happens, though, that
you get growth here.
And then, you get
stressed out because you
don't know what to do.
I mean, the important thing
is that you do the experiment
multiple times and you
have some reasonable rule
for treating these things.
Yeah, it can be more
complicated though.
All right, what
we're going to use
in the context of
this paper, though,
is we're just going to
assume that this MIC is
a measure for fitness.
The mapping from MIC to fitness
is, actually, very nontrivial.
Something my group has spent
a long time thinking about.
But for the purpose of this
paper, just when you hear MIC,
you can just say think
of it as fitness.
OK, [? higher ?] MIC,
he assumes that it could
be selected for by evolution.
So there are, in principle, 2
to the five different states.
Different versions of this gene.
So what he did is he
constructed each 2 to the 5
versions of the gene, put them
into the same strain of E-coli,
and then measured the MIC
of each of those 32 strains.
And that was all the
measurements in this paper,
basically because
everything else is just
analysis of that resulting
fitness landscape.
But what's exciting
about this is just
the ability to have an
experimental fitness
landscape because we've
talked about fitness
landscapes for years.
But then, it tends to be
much more like what you saw
in Martin Novak's book, right?
That you can think about
these fitness landscapes.
And you can do calculations
of what should happen on them.
But this is a case
where we can actually
just measure something akin
to a fitness landscape,
and to try to say what it means.
So you can ask questions about
how rugged is the landscape.
How many different paths can
you take from this version
to this version?
So first of all, how many
peaks were in this landscape
that he measured?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: One peak.
This is important.
This was the one and only peak.
And when you read this paper,
you come away thinking,
oh yeah, this is a really
rugged landscape, right?
Many of the paths were not
allowed by so-called Darwinian
or selective evolution.
But it's easy to forget that,
actually, it's not that.
It's a moderately
rugged landscape
because there was
still one peak.
In particular, if you just
assume that the population
starts at that minus,
minus, minus, state,
starts travelling
uphill in fitness,
gets a mutation and goes uphill,
is there any possibility for it
to get trapped in a non-optimal?
No because there
are no other peaks.
So there's only one peak.
That's the same thing
as saying that you
can take any path you
like going uphill,
and you will always get to
the same final location.
You will never get
stuck anywhere.
I mean, it does not
mean that you can take
any old path that you want.
Many of the paths may
be blocked in the sense
that they may go
downhill and so forth.
But at any location you're
at, there's always, at least,
one path going up in
fitness, up in MIC.
Doesn't matter
which path you take.
You will always be able to get
to the peak of this landscape.
OK?
So it's not too rugged of
a landscape, in that sense.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Wasn't
it, [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Right.
So some paths are not
allowed in the sense
that some paths decrease
fitness, locally.
But what I'm saying is that you
can take a different path that
goes up in fitness.
And you'll still get
to the same peak.
AUDIENCE: Right, but you
started in that [? wrong path ?]
and you [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Well no, no.
The thing is that you
can't take that path
because that path goes down
in fitness is the claim.
So the statement
from this paper is
that, if we just assume
that the only mutations that
can fix in a population
are mutations that increase
fitness, than it
does not matter which
of those beneficial
mutations you
take because you will always
end up reaching the peak.
So there are 120
possible trajectories.
Can somebody say how we got 120?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right.
So this is 5 factorial.
What he found by analyzing the
resulting fitness landscape
is that 102 were
selectively inaccessible.
Oh, I don't know how many--
is that the right way to spell
that?
Yeah.
And what he's assuming is that
the only mutations that can fix
are beneficial mutations.
OK, right.
In particular, if
you have two states,
there's a mutation
that you could acquire.
From here, let's say
you get this mutation,
and that just leads
to the same MIC.
He assumes that that
is inaccessible.
All right?
You know, and of
course, like all things,
you can argue about it.
What he's saying
is that it won't
fix in reasonable times,
which is fair if it's really
a neutral mutation.
In particular, if you
have 10 to the 6 bacteria,
and if the mutation rates
are the same everywhere
and some mutations lead
to a significant increase
in fitness, then
a neutral mutation
would be unlikely to fix.
So what he found is
that there were only,
then, 18 of the 120 paths off
this fitness landscape that
had monotonically
increasing fitness values.
And indeed, if you analyze
those trajectories, what
he found is that, actually,
18 [? isn't ?] maybe even
over [INAUDIBLE] because only
a few of those trajectories
would likely occupy
majority of what
you might call the actually
observed paths just because
of the statistics of when those
paths branch and so forth.
So the argument from
this paper is that we
can measure fitness landscapes.
And from it, we
can say something
about the path of
evolution, perhaps.
Other people have since
gone and done, actually,
laboratory evolution on a
different antibiotic resistance
gene-- again, Roy
[? Kashoney ?],
actually-- to confirm
that these landscapes,
at least in some cases, can
inform laboratory evolution.
So there is a sense that maybe
evolution is more predictable
than you would have thought.
We're out of time.
But if you have any questions,
please, go ahead and come on up
and ask them.
All right?
Thanks.